our domain and range and how do we
describe them hmm ya think for a second
I wonder if you remember what the
definition for domain is you know they
might have the set of X is that are
obvious good angers are defined for and
let's go with the language of into a
mess on a set of function mmm okay is is
pretty good this is pretty good I want
to add something to this a little bit
because let's think about this the set
of X values that are defined for a
function what does it mean that I
defined there like I say what is one
it's another snowball it's straight you
know um I'm not just to fighting the X
values all right it's actually the
function I'm interested in okay so I
want to say it's the set of X values
that enable only this I need is define
work on my commenter enable a function
to be defined okay let me give any to
let's go y equals 1 over X okay and you
can sort of picture it in your head
right now
what would the domain of this thing be
now I want to use this as a bit of a are
attending
not on those circles to describe - how
do you how do you define how do you
actually describe what the domain or
range or something is I'll until you
three right ways and one wrong way to do
it I need more colors so right and wrong
okay so here's the is the wrong way to
write the domain for this domain is X is
not equal to Y now I will keep your
hands up
well I'm sure some of you were probably
thinking that's that's the way I would
describe it in a right cuz I'm going
everywhere except for that okay now
let's just look back at this definition
that Raveena's came up with right um why
doesn't this work as an answer to this
yeah just ah okay so Cestius
are a bunch of numbers right some values
and this is a as the opposite it's a not
value so here's the way I would
transcribe it if I asked you what's your
favorite movie and if you asked me that
and I said not Twilight because I hate
what sorry if you're a liar what a
medical point if I said that to you
right if I said not Twilight okay that
doesn't answer your question yeah I
don't know what your favorite is because
I told you what my favorite is it that I
says okay so in the same way you haven't
described the domain you've described
what the domain is not okay so therefore
how do you do it there are three ways to
do it three five ways on three why ways
I'm going to give them to you in
increasing complexity okay so to sync
the simplest one is here and the most
the only one is down the boil okay so I
think it is raised to say X is less than
zero or X is greater because what's the
picture looks like this
okay and we've got some asymptotes in it
okay so when you look across this thing
where can where is the function defined
where has it got a definition well over
here X is less than zero we could write
you know this problem in the middle but
over here X is red zero you're fine okay
now a quick question
why is that or why is it not and
because particular teachers wanted it to
be that way okay let's extend the
question why did particular teachers
want it to be that way um my daughter
she's um she's four she has this thing I
don't think she gets the close-up to
favorites so when I say what's your
favorite color
she says pink and orange and green and
then she leaves all the color the
rainbow why I don't think you get what a
favorite is you cannot have one right
and you kind of come up is the color
which is all the bows at the same time
right and the same way if I set and read
control can you think of the number that
meets this condition and this condition
at the same time you might as well think
of a color that's finger like okay so
that's why particular teachers want it
this way
because war is right all right next
option you can say if you really like
this coin I just want to say one value
okay I would say all real values of X
except
except that one because that's the wrong
okay all real values of X I will get
into the other stuff but aren't real
later on I put that would do okay now
people don't tend to like this because
it's long and lazy okay so that gave
birth to the next option which is really
just saying this but in going to speak
even beyond that teacher happens I never
mind ah Jesse said yes reset right so if
I'm describing a set a natural way to do
that is to use set notation which
everyone hates because you did it three
years ago now I can remember it but to
refresh you his way works you start with
a curly brace and then you say X is
defined for the real number set its an
anymore but it's comedy so you can see
that's kind of close to where we started
and the wrong answer right but the
reason why I almost no I'm like you're
the the Stacey's and Victor Q's of the
world they kind of write like this
because they don't a very set notation
the rest of muscular I think there's a
column somewhere and like I don't know
who is that like a three or a one who
knows okay um so that's pretty hard to
know but I don't use it I go for this
one
that's nice okay we do whichever you
like any of those is fine this one is
not just like Twilight is not yeah
it goes right in me the prices and
interests right yeah do you mean do you
mean you just write this part yeah okay
so depends on how mean and how much
sleep and how much coffee though your
marker has had right now
here's the thing I hate like it's a bit
like you know subjects where it's just
it's so subjective and that kind of
thing it's always up to what the life is
sighs and I want to kind of avoid
putting my someone in position like that
honestly if my sword is my conclusion is
yeah they get it tick okay ah but it's
not so notation so I'm like do I have to
do you see what I mean and it puts the
marker and Con Ed aside
well how many marks is this question
worth and when you guys get your
half-yearly and we take you down to the
lecture theatre to give you an exam
review you get to see inside the
tortured soul of a mark i how difficult
it is actually when we get stuck with it
just another reason why i tend not to go
to this option okay
all right now if that's I just spent a
long time in Deming sorry but the reason
why is because we've done most the word
for range
what's range as above but for Y right
that's all
so